[music]
hello i am now you have to be the channel
sales lead for google cloud in the
region germany austria and
switzerland
my team and i support customers
in the region on their way to the cloud
and help them to use bruders technologies in such a
way that their companies can be
competitive  for the digital
future,
customers who tackle this challenge together with us
are companies from all industries and of
all sizes, such as
around sänger partner sap, but also companies
like rewe digital klöckner
kärcher or die sowende ag are the
first to use sap sv hänner and
netweaver  use on the google cloud platform
for about 18 months the demand
for google cloud platform services in
the region has increased exponentially,
so our customers and we are happy
about the launch of our newest cloud
platform region in frankfurt in
frankfurt has by far the highest
density of colocation  data centers in
Germany  tschland which makes it the optimal
location for all our customers
who want to implement their own multi or hybrid cloud
architectures with the best possible
performance
the new regions frankfurt means
speed
our performance tests have a
latency reduction of 40 to 60
percent compared to other hut
cloud platforms  region shown with the
opening of the latest cloud platform
millionen frankfurt is google steals your
new neighbor next door